si l'on en croit les résultats d'harris
interactive
48% des 10000 françaises interrogées
considèrent que la démocratie fonctionne
mal ou carrément que la france est un
régime autoritaire comme ça c'est clair
seul un français sur deux est satisfait
de l'état de la démocratie française et
le constat est le même du côté de cet
autre étude publiée par l'ifop ce
mercredi alors bien sûr il faut regarder
les catégories socio économique des
personnes interrogées d'abord on
s'aperçoit que ce sentiment d'un
dysfonctionnement de la démocratie
française est davantage partagée par les
électeurs ou sympathisants des partis
les plus à gauche et à droite et de
façon presque proportionnelle au niveau
de revenu en clair plus on est pauvre
plus on considère que la démocratie va
mal et inversement bon on ne va pas
passer en revue tout l'anc est notés
seulement ces quelques chiffres qui nous
ont interpellé 29 % des français jugent
les élections souvent ou toujours
faussés un tiers pense que le vote ne
sert pas à grand chose parce que de
toute façon les responsables politiques
ne tiennent pas compte de la volonté des
électeurs et trois quarts des personnes
interrogées pensent que leur opinion
n'est pas prise en compte par les
dirigeants politiques il faut dire que
ces dernières années ont mis à l'épreuve
le fonctionnement de notre démocratie
avec deux causes principales d'abord le
mouvement des gilets jaunes dont la
gestion policière a fait de nombreux
blessés graves d'ailleurs une partie des
demandes des gilets jaunes figure en
bonne place des mesures perçue comme
favorable au renforcement de la
démocratie comme la prise en compte du
vote blanc ou la mise en place du riq le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne mesure
on le rappelle écarté par emmanuel
macron à l'issue du grand débat et
deuxième cause identifiable la gestion
gouvernementale de la crise du coc vides
et les pleins pouvoirs sanitaire donner
à l'exécutif ainsi que les décisions
prises dans le secret de conseil de
défense que le parlement était prié
d'avaliser on peut ajouter à ça des
textes législatifs vus comme des
atteintes à la liberté d'expression ou
d'information comme les articles 24 de
la loi sur la sécurité globale et
l'article 18 de la loi sur le
séparatisme sans oublier la loi avia
censée lutter contre les contenus
haineux sur internet on peut noter enfin
que les français quelles que soient leur
appétence politiques semblent tous
largement plaidé pour la mise en place
d'un contrôle de la véracité de que
publient les médias médias et réseaux
sociaux figurent en troisième et
première place des menaces pour la
démocratie selon les sondés nous avons
donc une part de responsabilité dans le
sentiment du recul de la démocratie en
france ce n'est pas glorieux surtout
lorsque l'on remarque que plus d'un
quart des français pensent que la france
sera un régime autoritaire d'ici dix ans